concerning situation as your report said
this really has been a fraudulent show
trial we shouldn't give it any
credibility whatsoever there is no
evidence to back up these charges and
now we have two british citizens being
subjected potentially to
the death penalty they're not
mercenaries they are british citizens
who chose to join the ukrainian army for
personal reasons before putin's illegal
invasion of ukraine they were
captured by russian forces in mariopol
and they should be being treated in
accordance with international law and
the geneva convention which certainly
precludes show trials kangaroo courts of
this kind and the death penalty i want
the russian authorities now to step up
and to protect these individuals and
ensure that they are returned either to
the ukraine or back here to the uk as
soon as possible in accordance with
international law have you managed to
speak to the aslin family at all
i have i've known aiden's family for
many years i've known aiden for
almost as long as i've been a member of
parliament they're really good people
they've been through an appalling ordeal
whilst aiden has been in captivity with
the russians and now of course today is
the worst possible news for them
what we want to see now is the ukrainian
government
doing what it can to broker their
release and i've asked the foreign
secretary liz truss to summon the
russian ambassador to meet with her or
one of her ministers as soon as possible
to seek assurances about aidan and
sean's safety because it cannot be right
that british citizens are treated in
this manner irrespective of the
circumstances no one carrying a british
passport should be put on a show style
show trial from the soviet era and then
sentenced to death in this manner i mean
it's slightly complicated by the fact
this is not recognized
territory donetsk people's republic it's
going to be
very difficult to deal with these
separatists isn't it
well yes and no if vladimir putin wanted
to end this saga he could do tomorrow
these are his associates his proteges he
could step in and tackle this which is
why i think we need to deliver a very
clear message to the russian ambassador
that we expect russia to support our
british citizens and ensure that they're
treated in accordance with international
law
the ukrainian government and i've been
in conversation with ukraine ambassador
who's been extremely helpful for a
number of weeks are struggling to make
proper contact with uh these proxies
of the russians so it is a challenging
situation as you say but nonetheless
these are only affiliates of the russian
regime if putin wanted to resolve this
he could do and i expect him to respect
international law and the right to
british citizens even amongst all of the
terrible war crimes that he's committing
in this conflict liz trust saying it is
sham justice but she was the one that's
suggesting that britons could go to
ukraine and and fight now
what you say is absolutely true these
are not mercenaries these are regular
soldiers in the ukrainian army so
there's a difference but do you think
she was wise to say that in the first
place
well i i don't think it's sensible for
british citizens to go and fight in
foreign wars because obviously there are
immense risks when that happens but i
think in these cases it's extremely
important that we don't give any
credibility to
the lies frankly that are emanating from
this show trial or from the russian
regime these are british citizens for
personal reasons they were in ukraine
some time ago they chose to join the
ukrainian army before the invasion and
were perfectly normal paid up members of
the ukrainian armed forces they were
captured in conflict and international
law is absolutely crystal clear you
should be treated properly in accordance
with the geneva convention and returned
to your home country at an appropriate
time there are prisoner swaps happening
between the ukrainians and the russians
and shawn and aidan should be part of
one of those as quickly as possible
instead for political reasons the
russian government's proxies have hooked
them out of that and put them on this uh
this process kangaroo court we can't
give it any credence we have to call it
out and to demand that they get released
as quickly as possible and just finally
i mean it's possible as you sort of
suggest there that they it could be some
sort of bargaining exercise where
you know it all ends with some sort of
prisoner swap it's possible
after an appeal that you know the the
sentence is not carried out
yes well as i say there are uh prisoner
exchanges happening between the
ukrainians and the russians and we would
want these two individuals to be part of
one of those and treated in the normal
way as ukrainian
service personnel
we don't know exactly what the
intentions are of the russians and their
proxies in this case we shouldn't give
credence to that it's completely
outrageous situation and i do think it's
important that the foreign secretary
makes clear that british citizens cannot
be treated in this manner it's difficult
to think of direct parallels of british
citizens being put on show trials and
sentenced to death
this needs to be called out and this
needs to be resolved as quickly as
possible